how's it going guys my name's rose rose
you guys my name's Ben
[Music]
how's it going brooch how's it going
bros my name is Pippa welcome back to
arc also known as I can't read so I a
lot of you brothers have been telling me
that I can ride the dinosaurs and that I
can have sunglasses and I just wondered
why the [ __ ] have I wasted so much time
trying to survive when I could be doing
just that all right
stupid [ __ ] tree oh my God look at
that face you look like my next mistake
ha ha
what that [ __ ] is wrong with you help
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah
ok ah this is so annoying
come on we're not gonna die from a
[ __ ] dinosaur wait did I kill it I
killed it and I [ __ ] myself
I wish the Buddy Dodd it was just a
dildo deer died oh [ __ ] hell
that's pathetic there it is oh my god
what that [ __ ] you're a one sexy beast
wild Oh should I [ __ ] myself so awkward
I was just gonna hit on this girl hey
girl are you doing come on kiss me come
on kiss man
ah come on happens every time every girl
I like they just fly away
look it's my girlfriend Mickey a myth
yeah you can't you look so good Matt
yeah you look so perfect standing there
with your the pterodactyl underwear all
right let's set camp here somewhere
where's my [ __ ] fire [ __ ] hell
I can never [ __ ] find it my boots if
you place it down so we're clever then
you won't shut down there this see I
knew I was there because my girlfriend
is here thanks mate see I love you
hey agreement yeah
what's it your same page let's knock
some dinosaurs out of consciousness
kidnap them make them force them to be
my girlfriend and then I'll be free like
a Patera Decker oh [ __ ] I need water
fast Oh perfect wait yeah bad [ __ ]
shake dat ass for me shake that ass for
me come on girl a little like it when I
make that is my [ __ ] rekt hahaha
alright alright alright how do I look
I look like a lunch lady [ __ ]
beautiful I seriously do it looked like
my old lunch lady don't [ __ ] this up
pouch you get one chance in life to
slingshot a dinosaur always had a
Triceratops [ __ ] Triceratops you know
what let's try it on the dodo [ __ ]
please you like it oh no I killed him
ah Oh stupid
dodo I hate you and then kill her
actually I'm sorry Tina I love you oh
god she's [ __ ] fascist [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
nut this [ __ ] again she's [ __ ] hard
man
oh god she got friends what a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
Oh got that little [ __ ] oh you said
are you sad I got I don't think I should
[ __ ] with her ah
alright so as horrible as it sounds I'm
gonna chop this girl up wala she's
unconscious
I'm sorry
ah what the [ __ ] happened
[Music]
oh yeah
making boots gonna make some product
skin real leather dinosaur leather I
should be pretty expensive right am i
right
am i right why do I talk what what was I
did I call Tina semi team
Tina the moose yeah looking good
one day I'll learn how to cover up one
step at a time I'll become the ultimate
lunch lady's survivalist with the
greatest camera two entities that this
world has ever known
okay it's dark it's scary but we go home
so my two [ __ ] dinosaurs just
remember where you are
oh my god what the [ __ ] where did you
come from
[Applause]
[Music]